i think there's something wrong
mom
what is this
we need more colonies
[Music]
but that's a lot more work there's
nothing the two of us can't handle
together
[Music]
your life's so retro do you even have a
phone no so how do you talk to your
friends
my mom is my friend
[Music]
stop
turn it off
who are you
[Music]
what's going on
i'm fine i'm just worried about you i
said i'm fine
who is this woman that's my um
that was all she had
i remember so much
screaming
i didn't want you to know her
why
some koreans believe that life's
hardships are caused by the tormented
spirits of their
amanda you ancestors
i think there's something wrong
is this what you want a final resting
place
chris i'm coming
[Music]
come here
what else have you been lying to me
about
all of this is for you i can't wait to
leave
you're not going anywhere
a must here
you